onyx logic genomics is a program
dedicated to processing
analysis and interpretation of genomic
data
in this training program we will discuss
the basics what is dna
how to analyze genomic data and how to
interpret genomic variation
using multiple examples from high
profile research journals
program trainers include experts in
computational biology
bioinformatics and genomic medicine
where dna variation
is commonly used for diagnosis and
treatment selection
for those new to this field you will
find a brief review of the basic
terminology
the building blocks of dna code and
various types of dna variants
synonymous and non-synonymous mutations
frequency of variants
single nucleotide polymorphisms and copy
number variation
as a result you will become
knowledgeable in various terms used to
describe these variants
and master several examples of their
importance
in a number of different applications we
will also discuss the process of dna
sequencing and how analysis of whole
genome
and exome sequencing data can be used to
find variance and study association
between genotype
and phenotype this will become clear as
we review
project examples designed to illustrate
how bioinformatics is used
in real world research studies
biomedical research
and in the clinic for different parts of
the program we will leverage the onyx
logic resources designed to help you
learn about genomics
asynchronous coursework with theoretical
material quizzes and practical
assignments
cloud-based analytical server platform
where you will
analyze large genomic data and visualize
results
the rmx logic code playground where you
can practice coding in r and python
as well as a repository of curated data
sets
and project examples introductory
material
on genomic data with practical examples
that do not require a background
encoding
will be provided using the big data
analytical platform
t-bioinfo additional coding exercises
will also be used to practice
sequence alignment evolutionary studies
and interpretation
of found variants with over 3 billion
nucleotides we will spend some time to
consider the volume and variability of
genomic data
between individuals humans and the
animal models used to study human
disease
and the pathogens which also can be
characterized through their genomic
variants with the tremendous growth and
variability of
high throughput genomic data we will
also allocate some time to study the
history of genomic data
and explore various repositories data
types
and project examples that can be
leveraged to explore
and understand how bioinformatic
analysis of genomic data
is used and what is the future of
genomic data
these include examples from genetic
diseases like single cell anemia
somatic mutations in cancer dna
variation in cystic fibrosis
as well as mutations responsible for the
acquisition of drug resistant strains
in tuberculosis as well as viral protein
analysis for vaccine design
importantly we'll review in detail the
most up-to-date technologies used to
sequence dna
and rna and review the data formats
technical issues to consider in the
analysis
as well as data preparation pipelines to
structure genomic data
then we will turn to the powerful and
flexible cloud-based solution
that will allow all of the participants
to handle huge data sets
from hundreds of samples and extract
meaningful insights
from complicated analysis techniques
such as sequence alignment and mapping
analysis of genome and exome sequencing
variant calling and annotation
visualization of alignment
detection of somatic variants and copy
number variation studies
as well as genome-wide association you
will also get to practice these analyses
and develop an appreciation for tools in
r and python
to deal with data visualization and
scripting
we welcome you to join the omex logic
genomic training program
and leverage the opportunity to become
proficient at genomic data analysis
and bioinformatics